walking by himself without any help
Prince Philip seemed happy and relaxed
leaving the king Edward the seventh
Hospital the ninety eight year old was
picked up at a back entrance to give him
more privacy but the press were still
able to get the pictures that we wanted
four days after going in for treatment
to a pre-existing medical condition he
was finally on his way back to Norfolk
for Christmas with his family it came as
the palace released extracts of the
Queen's Christmas message after a
turbulent year both politically with
brexit and personally with family dramas
the theme is reconciliation she will say
how small steps taken in faith and in
Hope can overcome long-held differences
and deep-seated divisions to bring
harmony and understanding the path of
course is not always smooth and may at
times this year have felt quite bumpy
but small steps can make a world of
difference she talks about this year's
d-day commemorations and how in the true
spirit of reconciliation those who'd
formerly been enemies came together
adding that by being willing to put
differences behind us and move forward
together we honor the freedom and
democracy once one for us is so great a
cost her message also appears to be not
her own difficult year from Prince
Philip's car accident to Prince Andrew
giving up his royal duties because the
Jeffrey Epstein scandal and Prince Harry
and Megan being criticized for using
private jets and taking legal action
against the press the interview that
that the Duke of York gave was a
disaster and I'm you know I think nobody
understands why he did it he seemed
undecided he contradicted himself and he
made himself you know a laughingstock
which is really sad this new footage of
the Queen and her three heirs will also
appear in the Christmas message with the
monarch Prince Charles Prince William
and Prince George making Christmas
puddings for the British Legion for
generations working together even if
six-year-old George does look a little
uncertain about the small talk it shows
that away from the concerns
about Prince Phillip the Royals have
been preparing for Christmas as usual
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and their
son Archie sending out this electronic
cart they won't be at Sandringham for
Christmas but a helicopter leaving
Buckingham Palace was confirmation that
Prince Phillip was heading for Norfolk
shortly after he arrived the palace
issued a statement saying he wanted to
thank everyone for their good wishes
Rhiannon Mills Sky News